hello everyone welcome to another class
another lecture what did we do this week
we did a little bit of philosophy a
little bit of politics and you can
dismiss all that part which is probably
maybe 50% of what we did but we did a
little science as well and what was the
science part the scientific part let's
see if we can recap I started out on
Sunday I guess with mr. Sean Carroll
giving a presentation
he's a so-called physicist I call
mathematicians I think I'm saying these
people are not physicists regardless of
their titles mathematician from Caltech
he gave it a talk in the UK I think it
was London perhaps and he one thing that
struck me was that he kind of laughed at
the this music band the Insane Clown
Posse and these folks have a very famous
song the one-liner that I remember and
my son I think remembers for more or 3
more and the line goes like you know
freakin magnets how do they work and so
Sean begins his presentation well he
brings that up and says you know these
guys you know what do they know they're
just musicians of course we know how
magnet works in fact he says it was
demonstrated right there but he was
giving his talk he says Michael Faraday
explained it here you know 150 years ago
well it turns out that you know Mike
Faraday you know he died without
understanding how a magnet works and you
can see that if you read all his work
you'll find out that you know
he admits he can't figure out how it
works so he used this word he invented
the word field which is the word to
express or to depict or refer to the
region around the magnet he says I don't
know what's going on in there's some
matter in motion in there something is
moving there I don't know what it is I
can't figure it out but these are the
things that I've found in the lab this
is what I could measure this is what I
observe that kind of thing
but of course you cannot observe like
you know see with your eyes what a field
is because it's an invisible thing
whatever it is but he said it's there's
matter in motion in there or there's
something moving in there he just can't
figure it out what what it is that it's
moving and it turns out that you know
the modern people like Sean Carroll you
know he's just comes from that line of
thinking he uses the same word field but
today the word field nobody analyzes it
because everybody just takes it for a
physical object they say oh the field
the field does this the field does that
right and it turns out it's you know
Fielding's not a physical object so you
know so you can't really say you can't
really explain how how a magnet the
mechanism of how a magnet attracts
another by using the word field which is
what this fellow Sean Carroll does
specifically and this is what he said he
says action as distance this is what
he's trying to explain he makes a
relationship a relation to Newton's
gravitational force which is also an
action at a distance force and you know
he says field he defines it as a
potential or a value at each point in
space so it's a mathematical concept
this field thing it's just value at each
point in space the field gets stronger
or the force of attraction gets stronger
towards a magnet and as you get away
from it it gets weaker that's it and
that's what I feel is just a number a
value around a magnet or around the
earth if in case you're talking about
gravity and so you know you can't
explain with this concept
you cannot explain physical attraction
and if you can't then the mathematician
in this case mr. Carroll he has not
explained how a magnet works okay and
and so now we get into a different kind
of debate which is what we did I think
the next day and and you know see you
see one of the issues is you ask them
you ask a guy like Carroll or you or any
mathematician for that matter how does a
magnet work how does gravity work and
they cannot answer that question and
when you come with an alternative days
you're a crackpot you're crazy you're
you're crank and you say well why am ia
crank and the guy says well because you
you have an irrational theory I have an
irrational theory yes oh why is it
irrational and it's irrational why
because according to uh the
mathematicians because it doesn't meet
their specifications which is you know a
description a mathematical description
some kind of equation something that
they have verified over and over and
they all agree upon and if you clash
against that you are the crank but that
sounds like an opinion it sounds like
they're just you know be belittling me
or anyone by saying you are a rat you're
a crank you're a crackpot your theory is
dragged by and and that just sounds like
their opinion any kind of begs the
question at what point is it justified
to call someone a crackpot well if if
you hear everyone out if if if the
theory but that's where we get into this
nitty-gritty stuff from where we have to
define the word rational or irrational
especially if like in my case I define
science as rational explanations and I'm
saying whatever irrational doesn't
belong to science so now we get into
this fight of what do you mean by
rational what do you mean by irrational
these people calling me a crack
people call me a crackpot because my
theory classes against theirs well is
there an objective criteria to decide if
there's or mine is the true or the true
rational one maybe neither one is but do
we have a criteria for rationality to
call not the person that would be ad
hominem to say that the theory is
irrational okay or rational and do we
have some kind of objective criteria I'm
saying and these are the criteria that
I'm proposing and like my son said I'm
not really defining what irrationality
is I'm listening criteria so that we say
look whenever we use the word
irrationality or irrational whenever we
see a theory or here a theory is there a
way to objectively tell if the theory
physics right physics if the theory is
rational or irrational is there an
objective way and here it is I'm
suggesting these criteria I'm saying if
you treat a concept as an object you
know that's a concretization reification
that's a no-no in science that's okay as
poetry as good as a metaphor you know
love is a heart know love is not a heart
heart is one thing love is something
else love is a concept heart is a thing
and so you can't treat love as as an as
an object
likewise you can't treat the word field
as an object
you can't treat the word energy as an
object and of course you can see where
I'm going with this mathematical physics
trembles because I'm saying what they're
doing is irrational when they treat a
concept as an object and and again as we
discuss I think it was yesterday if you
use that as a poetry or for your closing
arguments to recap and say well you know
here I explained my theory perfectly so
that everybody understood now I'm gonna
use a little poetry to you know to close
for the closing gardener that's okay no
problem there but if the meet
the relevant part of your theory is all
literally irrational is concept turned
into opposite then we have a problem
with that at least in physics
and in science second one using
inconsistent definitions or undefined
words you know and the third one is that
the assumption is inconsistent with the
theory is inconsistent with the
assumptions that you started with which
you started your dissertation those are
the three primary ones okay there could
be some more and people would have to
break their heads on that right
according to this is there such thing as
an irrational video yeah yeah of course
of course no no right right no there are
irrational movies irrational you can
talk let's let's start slowly yeah
that's a critical question let's start
slowly a supernatural movie are there
yeah you can put God angels ghosts
spirits you can put all that on the
screen that's a supernatural one but are
they just not showing it's like I can
show a video of gravity is that rational
because we're not showing the invisible
thing if we're gonna talk if we're going
to talk about mechanisms I'll answer
that question at the end because that's
my punchline
that's my punch exactly the question you
ask it's at the hold that thought
hold that thought but I'm gonna answer
it because they yeah five hours later
okay anyway but it's it's it's the key
question right if if we look at grabbing
let's state the question right question
is if I show a pen dropping to the floor
right and I say oh that's gravity and
I'm gonna explain the mechanism and I
just show a pen falling to the floor
yeah I haven't shown any mechanism at
all
because when I'm talking about
explaining anything I'm talking about
explain I'm saying has to be put in this
no no I'm talking about I'm talking
about explaining if if you know we're
talking about physics again you know and
so if I'm saying I'm gonna say look I'm
gonna show you a movie I'm gonna make a
movie and show you exactly how the pen
or what caused the pen to fall to the
floor and all I just show is just a pen
falling to the floor and you look at it
you say well I don't understand the
mechanism mechanism oh you missed it let
me do it again I'll show the movie again
there's nothing there so hold that
thought that's the question okay you
know hopefully I'll answer it by the end
of the lecture today but let's let's
move on so the question then comes in to
what is physics because according to the
mathematicians none of this that you see
there this these irrationality issues
according to them none of that has
anything to what they call physics and
so now we get into another thought
another debate another you know struggle
here what is physics okay and so here we
get a description or definition from
them this is one that I found on the
internet but it's pretty close to
whatever you want out there in the
mathematical world thinks of when they
say physics and that it is a natural it
is a natural science based on
experiments measurements and
mathematical analysis essentially that's
it okay and I'm saying well hold it
that's kind of a little partial these
people are saying look since we do math
and we do equations and we can measure
and all we can do is get values then
we're gonna say that physics is that
what we just did which is experiments
measurements mathematical analysis it up
saying hold it and how about this you
know here here I have two magnets okay
pull them apart and they stick together
hey correct that's an experiment but my
point is it doesn't physics involve
trying to explain
how this happened isn't that a part of
physics insame that's why they call it a
natural science a natural science we by
that definition okay what do you mean by
the explanation physics is an
explanation based on yeah well they
didn't say exhalation it says natural
science based on there's no word
explanation in there in fact they don't
right right and and so in fact you won't
find the word explanation and either the
definition of physics or of science for
that matter do you think that's the crux
of it you would think so but they
dismiss that and say oh no that's on the
other side of campus that's philosophy
of physics philosophy of science that's
philosophy ontology mirror physics you
would I don't know how this magnet
attracts that one and you're saying this
is not part of physics no it's not
they say physics is measurement and
equations not causes and mechanisms oh
so now we do have a problem because all
these people they claim to do physics
and they're not doing explanation and
everybody asks them for explanations and
they give these [ __ ] explanations
for qualitative explains you know this
stuff and and people say but and then
people ask more questions than because
they said what do you mean a field puts
two magnets together what do you mean a
field is what causes an asteroid to hit
the earth you know and so people want to
have answers to these questions they
never get them because these people say
well you know this is the answer and
this is the answer and the more wide
question that you ask the more you upset
them and the more they said oh you
really got to take a course in math at
the college level to understand people
are asking qualitative and questions and
they're giving quantitative numbers and
the worst they're giving their giving
irrational physical interpretations to
their numbers to their equations so so
you say well what do you what do you
mean you gave me this
wants to know the quality right is this
work and that's where there's no meeting
of the minds between the mathematicians
in the rest of the world out there
because the rest of the world they don't
care about the math they don't care
about the exact speed of light and none
of that nonsense all people want to know
is you know just a simple stuff what do
you mean gravity is the warping of
space-time what do you exactly mean by
warpage of space side what do you mean
for dimension why is it unimaginable and
so they have no answers to these
questions and so they give you all these
[ __ ] answers because they are
[ __ ] meaning you know irrational my
son says I should use the word
irrational to characterize them but see
they use crank and crackpot to refer to
me right so so I have a problem with
that because that's a one-way direction
I'm saying they're the crackpots because
they give a rational but okay but so
let's call that politics but we have or
we can have objective criteria for what
is rational in physics and once you
define that or but these give the
criteria like I did a minute ago I can
safely say using that criteria that what
they're doing is irrational in other
words their theories are irrational and
they say well yeah and and they do
agreed to some degree because they all
pretty much say well you know there's a
lot of stuff we don't understand we
don't understand entanglement and we
don't understand you know exactly how
the slit experiment works or how
polarization is done because we used a
wave but then you know what quantum uses
the particle and the particle is not
really a particle it's a wavefunction
and so you know you get into all this
stuff and you lost the guy the normal
person on the on the streets looks at
all that says you know yeah this is
beyond me no what are you guys are so
much so such big geniuses no they're not
geniuses they're idiots
keep that in mind they're the irrational
people they're giving you any physical
interpretation that is irrational
according to criteria that I've got here
so they're not geniuses at least in the
qualitative sense now if they're
geniuses in the quantitative sense I
don't care because we're not asking for
a quantitative expert description or
information that's the issue
you worry too much about the politics of
science when you're censored when the
system says I'm not saying that they're
out to get me I'm not saying that I'm
saying the system is already designed or
the way it's evolved to perpetuate
itself it's it's more or less like what
happened with Christianity in a Western
world in the up to the Renaissance up to
the time of the Protestant revolution
right all these people Martin Luther and
John Calvin and so on you know up to
that time you know the Pope's and the
Cardinals they were they were the law of
the land and they were the intellectuals
so they told you what to believe they
interpreted the Bible for you in fact
they said look don't read the Bible
hopefully you can't read the Bible
because you're ignorant and most people
were illiterate but those who can please
don't try to read the Bible because you
won't understand it you want
understanding you got to go to Sunday
School will interpret it for you and
this is exactly the same thing look you
don't understand math don't try to
interpret it in your qualitative world
you won't understand you wouldn't
understand it you got to come and take a
course in college where we will teach
you what to believe okay that's the way
it works right now
and that's there no different than what
happened in the days of Luther so what
are these guys - they had to overthrow
the existing regime because there was
something wrong with the regime the
existing regime at the time the same
thing right now right now these people
are giving you irrational qualitative
interpretations and they're saying we
know well if you know then why don't
can't you explain well we can't express
math in ordinary language that's why
well that's kind of wrong because see
you when you say you know the dog jumped
through the window everybody understands
yeah you know you can put it pictorially
you can show the movie you can tell me
that we'll all understand why can't we
do that with two magnets here we have
two physical objects that we can see and
touch
is the entire system that's how simple
this thing is two pieces of metal why
does it do that
why does one pull on in and why when you
turn them around they repel each other
yeah I can't put them together see they
they they dance around they don't like
each other why is that why do I need to
understand math any amount of math an
equation any formula any variable to
understand that physically there should
be a mechanism and there's only one way
to come up with a mechanism and that's
to make an assumption about the
invisible entity is the invisible matter
if we want to call that that's moving in
that region between that these people
Caulfield
that's what Faraday and both Faraday and
James Maxwell said they studied magnets
quite a bit they said look we don't we
don't really know what's going on in
there but they're in there there's a
matter in motion and what none of the
mathematicians art of today have been
able to do from can bridge all the way
to Harvard to this day is identify what
is moving in there
and so they lost whole name they dropped
the ball and they said look we're not
gonna deal with that issue anymore
that's high school stuff we we couldn't
figure it out we left it behind now
we're just gonna describe the field and
it gets stronger towards a magnet and we
could farther away period that's it
that's all you get and so when you come
with qualitative questions you know they
send you away they give you the
runaround fine and say well you got to
take math if you if you really want to
understand that's the status of
mathematical physics today okay so yeah
what is physics not this whatever you
see there is not physics and here we
have a confirmation by emeritus
professor Donald Simonet from Lock Haven
University in Pennsylvania and he says
science doesn't explain science
describes we're not going to give you
any qualitative answers that you are
seeking we are just going to describe
mathematically and then we're going to
give you a physical interpretation and
if you tell us to go to hell we said
well you know
you got to take a math course to really
understand that yeah that's the
situation today and that's why you don't
get any answers none whatsoever from the
mathematical establishment you will
never find a rational answer to normal
everyday phenomena you don't know what
light is they say a series of particles
well how do you do the slit experiment
and the answer is the particle is at two
places at once according to the
uncertainty principle what how does a
magnet attract another through a field
what is a field a bunch of values around
the magnet huh how does that produce
attraction and so on you know what is
why does a galaxy rotate in a certain
way because there's dark matter what is
dark matter well we don't know because
it's invisible and very heavy what's a
black hole well we don't know because
it's invisible and very heavy you get
the same answer yeah it's and so you
never you're always lost you say well I
don't understand you said well you gotta
take math can understand and that's
where we find a problem so so what
happened in fact here you know I show an
example here's what an equation is for
those who don't know is a simple
equation force equals mass times
acceleration right what is an equation
equation is one value only one value per
a shot in other words you're gonna
replace values for the f-4 force in this
case for acceleration the little aid and
you're gonna try to figure out what the
mass is of this object okay so you have
you plot force against acceleration you
get one point along the graph so you're
gonna get you know if you have half the
force in Newton's in this case you get
half the force you get two as the
acceleration two meters per second
square if you get one Newton one unit of
force you get four meters per second
square in acceleration and so you can
only plot one point if you replace the
on the second equation their mass equals
force over acceleration if you just
replace the F and da with numbers you
get one value for math
then you got to do it again you got to
now replace the F with another number
the a with an unknown number and you get
another value for mass maybe you know
maybe you get the same value but the
point is all you can get for mass is one
value at a time and you plot these
values right on a line that's all you do
does this process does that even the
results of it does that give you a
mechanism of how a magnet attracts
another or how the earth attracts you
know an asteroid or whatever you know
what we're talking about is is
abstractions mathematical threats and
all these are just descriptions it's a
quantitative description it doesn't tell
you the why the cause the mechanism and
so the question is does physics deal
with causes and mechanisms or this
physics deal with numbers and just
descriptions for the values that's
that's what the debate here is about
okay so let's put all that in the proper
context okay so what's next I'm saying
these guys are you know the guy who does
this is really uh he's not a physicist
if what they do is measure and give
values they're surveyors that's that's
the correct term for these
mathematicians oh they're doing a survey
yeah you know they put their equipment
there they take a measurement they go to
the lab and they put it into a nice neat
equation what is that that's a surveyor
so I call the surveyors from now on okay
I like that word you're not on but
you're not a physicist you're not even a
mathematician you're a surveyor you do
measurements okay they used to call
geometers in fact the the orders at the
Greeks to Brydon being called geometers
uh was it Plato on his Academy the wall
he had supposedly he had a sign saying
that no person who's not a geometers may
enter here they put the word geometry
not mathematician not physicists they
said anyone who is not a geometry we
don't want them in here okay and now the
mathematicians are saying the same thing
in their club today they're saying if
you don't know math we don't want you in
here okay so when you come in there with
a
qualitative question like why is this as
soon as you mentioned the word why'd
they say look go to the other side of
campus and or take a course in the
philosophy of physics or philosophy of
science don't bother us if you want to
understand what we are doing you got to
take math and so well you go to the
other side of campus and and you find
what you find these you find the
philosophy the philosophers the
philosophy of physics or the philosophy
of science what do these people do okay
and here you find if you look it up on
the Wikipedia you find philosophy of
space and time that's one of the things
that they have under the contents of
philosophy of physics and what do they
look at they look at the word time
oh man that must be exciting I travel
and in the time travel these are the
important things that philosophers of
science or philosophers of physics do I
just mind time travel doesn't work I
mean the word paradox and movies usually
yeah yeah killing your grandfather you
know yeah well yeah what is it Back to
the Future the guy goes back and forth
funny encounters himself in one of his
trips and then and then another guy
comes in and encounters two of them in
fact Brian Greene shows that in one of
his scientific presentations where he
goes back he's got all these Brian
Greene's around him you know it's a
quantum slash relativistic world you
know so the alternative version you
already till matter what you do yeah but
you get a problem gonna end up yeah but
hold it hold it we got a problem because
soon as you go to the past you already
change the past and if that's the future
for your great-great-great
great-great-great grandfather then you
did change his future
so you know just know it's it's
irrational against your ration but they
try to get a waiter and say I love
travel movies but this is a feature of
reality is important to make sure that
it's dumb to make sure that it's unreal
you kind of dove into it you you you go
through every you know at least the
template scenarios and you find out very
quickly that okay is there is no way
twin paradox there your your twin
brother is 50 years older than you
wearing one is if we had if the
time-travel existed we'd have time
travelers jumping into our time right
now correct no no but they have a
solution for that see yeah we have the
block universe you can go forward in the
block universe you can't go backwards in
other words they have to cover guys we
go because they said you know if time
travel is true why hasn't anyone from
the future come to visit us and they say
because you can only travel for forward
in time not backwards in time so they
fixed it my grandfather would die of a
heart attack
who are you I'm your grandson whenever
they make time machines that's probably
where you want to stay yeah okay and so
you can see the subject matters that the
philosophers of physics are doing the
Everett interpretation that's the
many-worlds interpretation uncertainty
principle particle can be at two places
at once
two particles two different particles
can occupy the same location or position
whatever it's it's all irrational so the
philosophers of physics who are doing
all this stuff they're just dealing with
irrational things where did they get all
this nonsense
they got all this nonsense from the
physicists so-called visitors who fed
them all this garbage and so these guys
are now you know they hammered a nail in
the air and now they're hanging from and
trying to hammer another one for drew up
above there they're standing on
quicksand
[Music]
just electric universe that's why I kind
of like these that they at least
entertain the thought but I think you're
right that it kind of is very telling
the topics that they talk about because
that shows where they're getting them
from the site you only get the Everett
interpretation Oh time travel space and
space time where do you go to have
travel everyone that smoked the bomb
talks about time travel yeah so so if
this is the philosophy so so when you go
to the other side of campus you get more
irrationality and you said where did you
get this we got it from the physicists
what do you mean if it yeah the
mathematical physicists they they fed us
this nonsense and we deal with this non
so we deal with this in rationality
everyday at the water cooler and write
books about in seldom become rich so so
neither one
no one's dealing with the issue no one's
telling me how a magnet attracts another
neither these guys none of the other
guys okay because the other guys get
their cues from these guys and so we've
got you know people from one Asylum
talking to the people to the patients of
the other Asylum that's what we have
right now okay so let's let's move on
here and what's next well so the
question is whether we we get to this
point which we got to yesterday whether
you know physics or science or actually
physics you know whether it's got to do
with descriptions or explanations and
the first thing we have to clarify here
is the difference between the
description and an explanation
99% of humanity plus 99 cetera they have
no idea what the difference is and the
reason for this is we get these words
out of ordinary speech and we do not
look at them in any detail we do not get
to the bottom of them for science we
cannot say we cannot use the word
describe like we use in ordinary speech
someone comes to you and says describe
what happened
well that's outlawed in physics or
should be outlawed that's what I'm
recognized I'm trying to yeah in essence
yeah but this is what I'm trying to get
to I'm saying the word describe the word
description should be used for objects
you describe a chair you describe a tea
tree you describe what a dog is you know
that kind of thing
description objects what do we use
adjectives okay that's that's a
description strictly speaking and when
I'm proposing it for science and for
physics specifically explained is
something else explain is to illustrate
the causes and mechanisms that's what an
explanation is a qualitative explanation
tell me how tell me the mechanism how a
magnet attracts another tell me a
mechanism of why or what caused the pen
to fall to the floor or the moon why
doesn't it leave the solar system you
know give me a mechanism that's an
explanation and in between you have this
hybrid which we talked about yesterday
with my dear son here and it's the word
narrate which I'm introducing what is a
narrative or to narrate
I'm saying that's just and and I'm gonna
go in more depth with this but it's a
chronological listing of events that's
all I think it does when is movies that
tell sequences out of order and right
right okay yeah you're right but then I
thought about that but see the sequence
on the frames I guess we should word
this in a different way chronological
frames
well it's car logical in the sense that
even though the guy goes back in time
you know somehow or whatever and says
look back time-travel is a perfect you
know all these movies with time travel
is a perfect example you know the guy
goes to when he was born so so there's
this part in the movie where the guy
shows up when he when he was born and so
it's like it's not in chronological way
but it is chronologically in the movie
so in that sense I was thinking of no no
I understood that what I'm saying is the
frames on the movie the way I watch them
on the movie is one frame right after
another you know even even though this
is this yeah yeah it's chronologically
well know right and that's what I'm
saying chronologically in the movie well
okay fine but there's a movie called
memento which literally goes backwards
yeah yeah I know but still the the
frames of the film go forward no I mean
the frames how do you know it went
backwards because the you know the guy
is moonwalking you know I'm walking
backwards forward but his feet are going
backwards okay but whether we put the
word chronological or not I don't think
it's so crucial it is a listing of
events and you would think that
narrative can narrate if you're gonna do
a listing of events that's eventually
that's gonna equate to explanation the
bottom line well if you're trying to
explain something you well let's find
out that's true but you could just
narrate something with our own
explanation okay but I'm referring it
specifically - explanation is a
narrative the same thing as an
explanation is to narrate is to narrate
the same thing as to explain what that's
or could it be the same for the purposes
of physics and I'm saying it's not okay
that's gonna be hard but I'm saying it
doesn't always have to be at least I'm
gonna argue that doesn't always have to
be now with my son we're gonna beat our
brains later on in the kitchen find out
if it could be
you'll sleep on it okay so right now all
I can say is that not always are these
the same
why aren't they the same and let's see
if I can illustrate this here is narrate
verses explain according to me okay
I'm saying that a narrative is you know
you're watching a film strip and all
you're doing is watching one frame next
to the after another so you have you can
put it in other words you can put the
narrative in pictures okay you can say
look this is what happened and so what
I'm looking at is really not a movie
what I'm looking at is a film strip I'm
looking at the film itself and I'm
looking at the frames and I'm saying
okay I see what happened in this frame I
see this frame this frame this frame
different but I don't understand the
mechanism and and hold down for a second
I know that it's not completely clear at
this moment I'm gonna try to make it
clear explain this the bottom picture
you know you show the movie on the
screen you watch it and you see you see
it run you see it move the other one the
narrative is just a sort of description
per frame whereas this one is running a
movie and you say well bill I still
don't understand it's not clear to me
and I'm sure that up to this point it's
still not clear let me see if I can make
it clear we got to go slowly yeah okay
so let's make it clear yeah okay here we
have it I'm saying narrative is not an
explanation not equal to an explanation
why I can illustrate the scenes in a
narrative right and let's talk about not
physics let's talk about philosophy
let's talk about history psychology any
of the things that I include under
philosophy which is you know physics
these were deals with objects and
philosophy deals with concepts and here
I'm gonna say look I can illustrate the
scenes I can illustrate Napoleon going
to Waterloo fighting on his horse
against another
right 18:15 so I can show you the movie
and you can watch the movie and say okay
I see what happened I see that Napoleon
took his horse his army he went to
Waterloo 1815 they threw you know
cannonballs at each other and Napoleon
lost okay that's the plot of the movie
you understood the plot of the movie
what I cannot illustrate for you on that
screen is what was going through the
mind of Napoleon I cannot tell you why
he went there that what was his reason
for his purpose for going to Waterloo
for that I cannot illustrate that I have
to tell you you know and you saw the
silent movies in the days of Charlie
Chaplin and they had subtitles they look
something like this for those who
haven't seen one millennial guys or
whatever they're too young you'll see
something like that they would come up
on the screen between pictures between
the frames you know you see the guy
doing something a Charlie Chaplin doing
some kind of slapstick but you didn't
understand the whole thing so you say so
the director had to put something in
there between tell you why don't forget
to set those sliders to zero in her good
frequencies we don't want to defin her
so now you know why they did something
they didn't want to defin her you
wouldn't understand that by just
watching the movie you need that that
block of words in there it's interesting
because I think that is the difference
between because some people could
understand it without the text like
assuming you like you work with deaf
people and you know what those dials are
for and you see them not turning it up
all the way like someone could watch a
video of then be like oh no I know why
they're not turning it all the way up
but they put in that extra text to make
sure that like cuz that's the crux of
the matter that's when it comes to
explaining something oh you mentioned
the the right word example perhaps a
deaf person I show you a movie I showed
the et the the Klingon he visits us from
outer space right he comes to earth and
I show him a movie and what do I show I
show someone hollering
hey Jodie and a person doesn't turn
around that's what I show and the et
says why is it he's being called saying
Joey Joey turned around there's a train
coming
why isn't he turning around he trying to
commit suicide well he doesn't
understand that that guy is deaf and he
can't hear and I can't show you that in
the picture I have to put the little
sign like in the subtitles in the movies
in the old movies
this guy is deaf he can't hear okay okay
fine so mad what I'm saying but you can
yeah but your hand on this guy's
probably mute or maybe he wants to
commit suicide for all we know but yeah
but what I'm saying is you kid know
exactly the cause what's causing this
guy not to turn when his reason is for
not turning around what his purposes may
be started commit suicide that's why he
doesn't he's not listening or maybe
stuff and he can't hear so so you don't
understand why unless you get that
subtitle you know the the silent movie
words in there saying this guy is deaf
okay now I understand until then I don't
understand what we're talking about the
[Music]
summary kind of what makes it part work
understand but with the narrative you
could talk about the car being read and
then it's up to the person listening a
Big O is read what makes the car work is
that part important right right yeah you
could get to get things out putting a
fine point on what you could get you
could get the explanation wrong because
maybe you you conclude that it's red you
know the color red that means it's with
a narrative you're not answering a
question with an explanation you're
always answering the question yes like a
robotic it's like you just mentioned
facts or description
answer a question no no but what I'm
saying it's it's like a series of
descriptions for that's why I've used
the frames of a film ends and ends in an
example it can be wrong but when I'm
trying to focus on here is that a
narrative is just just the facts ma'am
just the facts
well he Jo you went to the store and
from there UN it's like it's just a
listing of facts yeah but that's not the
difference between explanation without a
question let's put it that way okay
that's good
yeah but there is narrative without a
question most narratives are questioned
because they're not trying to answer a
question right you're just they're just
telling you a story telling you
something could be but in that sense you
kind of turn into an explanation like
you automatically go into explanation
territory when you're a scene when
you're specifically answering a question
when it's not answering your question
there's more in there than maybe that's
the difference well I apply this you
know again we can't say that when
mathematicians like Sean Carroll goes
out there and gives you an irrational
qualitative explanation that we need
caught we can't call that an explanation
he might say well you know it's a
description mathematical description we
interpret it but see a description is
again four objects
what he's doing is narrating okay now
the question is whether that narrative
that he's giving you equates to an
explanation and that's where that fine
line comes in when these people say well
I've explained it no you have it what
why hasn't he explained it well I'll
give you an example here here's the
example here's mr. uh yes mr. Sean
Carroll and he gave his presentation and
I'm saying that he's doing a narrative
he's saying he gives you an image of a
field in fact uh somewhere in here I had
a I didn't put it up there don't have it
no I don't have it anyways he gives you
he puts a field out there
right he he puts a picture of a field
let's assume he can do that he
put some lines in there and you say okay
so is this the physical object that
brings two magnets together is this what
brings you know the moon or what what
the earth uses to attract the moon or a
parachutist or or is this the reason the
moon doesn't fly out of the solar system
and he might say yes and you say well
what do you mean by field and he said
well it's a bunch of numbers its values
its numbers Oh hold it
you know I you can't illustrate values
or numbers you can't elissa be these are
abstractions so now I can't see on the
screen what the mechanism is for
attraction using the word field so I
don't have an explanation as of this
moment the word field has not given me
that information has not given me the
causes it's not Illustrated the
mechanism there's an explanation have to
be Illustrated know what I'm saying what
I'm saying is if if we illustrate we
illustrate we can watch the movie and
with a movie understand the mechanism
fine we have an explanation but if you
watch the movie and whatever you saw
there did not give you the mechanism the
cause then you do not have a all you
have is a narrative but you do not have
an explanation yeah of course you can as
long as you Allah straight with words
and the other person understands
howardino no hold it but well hold it
but if the other person understands the
words that use and the words represent
objects then you have a mechanism
because a mechanism involves objects
only but if the guy is gonna use
concepts as object which is what this
fella did Sean Carroll you know you
watch each frame but not understand the
physical mechanism why because you don't
know how assuming you know assuming
let's go with best-case scenario and
let's go in their favor let's let's just
play a devil's advocate here let's
assume that they represent each point in
space with a ball particles right
quantum mechanics fine so now we have
values all around the magnet we have all
these little points and he
represents them with a bunch of balls
and you say okay I watched a movie I see
what you're saying you're seeing that
there's more balls or the density of
balls gets greater closer to the manga
or the balls get stronger or there's
higher density or something towards the
magnet you haven't explained a minute
how did the balls pull and so just by
watching the movie you have a narrative
because the guy tells you step by step
chronologically if necessary or
uncritically he tells you you know what
his idea what his mechanism is in his
mind but you're saying yeah but I still
haven't understood the mechanism how do
the balls you know attract you know two
magnets together and that's where the
guy said well you gotta take math and so
you'd have not understood the mechanism
the explanation just by watching the
movie even though he can illustrate it
with balls and that's my point
an explanation something different now I
always say that yeah picture is worth a
thousand words and not to mention a
video videos worth a million words you
watch some videos here I understand how
other window broke and the the dog the
one that you're proposing you know the
dog jumped through the window and broke
the glass okay so I understand it
perfectly just by watching the movie you
know that I can see it maybe I need to
put some words in there and help you
you know interpret that but watching the
movie will give you an idea what
happened in that same way you have to
try to explain how to man you subtract
each other and this is not what they do
they what they do is look well we'll
illustrate and we'll illustrate it with
balls right little ball tiny tiny dots
and you say how do they do that well we
don't know that's the answer the answer
is you got to take a course in math
advanced math in college to understand
quotations there right understand what
we're talking about that means you know
and all they can do is describe as mr.
Donald there was his name what's his
name
Donald Simic and he said you know
science doesn't explain science
describes and that's where the problem
is that they do not explain and so when
you go with a qualitative question to
these people you're lost and you're
expecting a qualitative answer and you
get an irrational reply based on the
criteria I put up there
objects are simply concepts that are
turned into objects there are no solid
rigorous definitions they say well we
just need more words that define words
and those need to have many words as
well and so you know we can never it's
also it would be corrosive as we can
never define the word very perfectly you
know and this is not the issue the issue
is criteria you know are you gonna use
for the word object for example are you
gonna use you know
maths are you gonna use volume or you
know what criteria you gonna use are
you're gonna use shape motion you know
see touch what criteria are you gonna
use that's where we call that a
definition and you know as long as you
have a spec we can use it objectively
and say okay whenever we mentioned the
word object we'll refer you to something
that has shape that means you have to be
able to illustrate it and if you come
with 4d space-time said what's
unimaginable we're here let me tell you
my theory the guys already out of the
starting point you know he can't even
start his presentation because he
doesn't even have a valid object and
that's the kind of thing that they're
doing they're not defining their terms
are not using rational objects meaning
they're using concepts as objects you
know field mass-energy and you say what
is energy well we don't know but let me
continue you know that kind of thing and
then you have the other issue where you
know the theory the explanation if there
is one doesn't follow from the
assumptions you know and one that I can
give you as an example is you know
particles you say particles okay I got
the particles and now the explanation is
that you know a gluon which is a
particle pulls two quarks together you
say well how did you do that I mean the
theory doesn't follow from the
assumption if you put a hook there or a
rubberband you say well this is this is
these two balls come together as a
rubber band holding them together and
you know these guys are doing this okay
I can understand that but you say
particles well how did the particle
produce the attraction so the theory
doesn't follow from the assumption and
so these are the criteria we should
apply to the mathematical physicists
when they give you a physical
interpretation for their equations if
it's irrational we have to say it in
their faces
you gave me an irrational physical
interpretation no nobody said what you
said the other day what did you say
chemists and biologists no problem but
there was and and the reason is is is
you know that chemists paleontologists
all these people they work with things
greater than an atom so they don't have
problems in talking about skulls you
know they talk about a skull and you say
okay I know what he's talking about he's
not saying look I have a bit of energy
in my hand no he's saying I've got a
skull in my hand and then you only
debate the black eyes are because I
don't agree with this theory that's a
different issue but at least the guy
brings you a skull he said we're gonna
talk about skulls today what does the a
chemist come with he says I'm gonna come
with a compound you know I'm gonna come
with DNA or I'm gonna come with I don't
know Salt Lick yeah liquid or whatever I
probably some disease oh yeah so it's a
the guy does something there but what
are the mathematicians come these
so-called physicists mathematical
physicists they come and they say well
what have you brought today - for
show-and-tell
I brought energy and I brought mass and
I brought force and I brought
interactions and here I have a particle
which is really a wavefunction and it's
carrying an interaction you say what the
hell what's what's this what's this guy
talking about and then the guy said well
you gotta take the course in math at the
college level to understand what we came
here
to discuss today and that sounds like
show-and-tell without the tongue without
the show Show & Tell meets the Emperor's
New Clothes yeah something in my hand I
swear but you kind of have to only a
true scientist conceded yeah this is the
great problem with mathematical physics
that's why it's garbage that's the
correct word now my son doesn't want me
to beat little the mathematician say
don't call him irrational poor guys you
know they say these guys make big bucks
they're celebrities they called you a
crank and a crackpot but they want to be
left off the hook because they have the
backing of other math yeah but nobody
hears about the public large emanuelly
the public at large as well that's why I
get my little vengeance that needs being
able to throw my little stuff at them
okay
could be but anyways the point here is
that I have no qualms Konomi irrational
because I have a criteria a set of
criteria if they want to call me crank
crackpot irrational fine please give me
a criterion that is objective don't tell
me that all the buddies that you know at
the asylum
all the patients voted together with you
that I'm a crank no no if you're gonna
vote please give me an objective
criteria for irrationality is a crank
for a crank good there should be no
voting period right no no give me give
me a criteria for why I'm a crank what
is it crank and you know mr. John Baez
he came up with the crackpot index fine
if you look at all that a lot of that is
opinion in fact I think all of it was
opinion I don't think he has a single
valid objective criteria in there but
you can apply that talk about theories
with with with the rational mind logical
mind without muddying it with all these
you know who's a crackpot who is it okay
do we censor who don't you're the new
generation nobody has to say I don't
care he's a bum off the street
okay but you can apply you can apply
like John biases criteria not to people
you can apply them to a theory you can
say okay let's see what his criteria is
and instead of attacking the person you
ant hominin just go in there and say
okay let's see let's look at your theory
versus these points I don't think
there's a single valid objective
criterion in his whole list I'd have to
look in there I know most of them are
not I think none of them are I would
have to go through there and find out a
single criterion that he puts in there
is rational is its objective is right
crackpot theory or crank the theory
index then then be okay because then
you're attacking the theory seriously at
some point in your life at some point
you go to like sit down be okay why are
they wrong
well it's human nature to say that if
you have an irrational theory then
you're also irrational that's that's how
it goes in in that chain of events
there's no human nature in a science
conference correct it should be
objective science physics is not
generator right it should be a
scientific non human nature there's only
nature we shouldn't have to vote we
shouldn't have to say you're wrong and
I'm right
you're incorrect I'm correct you're
false and mine I'm true you know we
shouldn't have to say that but the
theory should be criticized with
objective criteria and I've provided
three criteria
you know converting concepts into
objects that's prohibited undefined
words or words used inconsistently
throughout your presentation that's
irrational and your theory doesn't
follow from the assumptions that's
irrational and and so you know that's
subjective
you know you don't have to take my
opinion you can apply that criteria that
any theory even mine and say let's see
it doesn't follow this criterion and of
course the mathematicians won't like
that fact I got two negative votes in my
presentation on on rationality the other
day and they came from
when Korah who obviously you know their
religion suddenly you know started
stumbling they didn't like that and of
course it threatens anybody's religion
because if you have many or a theory
that is founded on irrational concepts
such as you know converting concepts
into objects undefined words and so on
then yeah you're gonna tremble you won't
like someone like me you know trying to
put you against the ropes and saying
okay tell me exactly what you mean by
this word and you said well that we
can't define words you know the words
are need words which need more words in
which you need more words and he tries
to get away from defining and over
asking us for criteria so that we can
figure out what's going through his mind
and for sure when he's using a concept
in patently obvious concepts such as
energy as a physical object saying
transferred energy what do you mean you
transferred energy you transferred
information there's no such object in
science so if you want to do poetry
that's next door you you hear this is a
scientific conference here you got to
speak with objects you can transfer a
dog you can transfer a tree you can't
transfer energy or information and so
when yous transfer information to answer
energy you're irrational it's okay to
use it again one more time as closing
argument but not to express your theory
or the main point of your theory you
can't use it not in science and of
course all these people won't like that
because they've been using these terms
for at least 200 years now legally yeah
and that's the point the point there
they don't use them legally because
they're using it to really present their
theory and you're saying I haven't
understood your mechanize what do you
mean you transferred energy what do you
mean you transferred information they're
using force as a baseball bat they said
I hit you with force now you hit me with
a baseball bat not with force
all right to finish off I got our motto
this is closing argument okay closing
argument suppose no human nature only
nature oh okay so we have closing client
that's the corollary of the kind of
no human nature and I'm and I'm kill you
that a second only nature yeah yeah only
nature I'm guilty that you know I guess
because the way I was raised my my
people from my generation I was born in
1952 the 65 years ago so you know I I
have a different mindset about these
things
I'd rather confront and fight other
people would rather you know be a little
more calm and I don't mind fighting as
long as this for the right thing you
know I don't mind its own species mind
as long as he's hitting the right notes
but you know you know always when you
argue debate or whatever against a
mathematician if you go like like I
mentioned that comment yesterday if you
ask why too many questions you're gonna
piss them off and at some point the
guy's gonna say I leave my room get out
of here okay and and that's and that's
where the problem is the problem is that
at some point you do put on the gloves
and you start getting black eyes with
these people it's like you can't avoid
it eventually anyways we'll see you on
Sunday again and same time same station
we'll see you then bye bye